Sebastiaan albick has been with the
German company Eisenman in Mexico for
almost a quarter of a century he heads
its subsidiary there and last year was
its best year to date al Beck is heading
from headquarters in Puebla to the new
facility in querétaro north of Mexico
City it was finished last year it's
situated in an industrial park along
with many other internationally owned
auto parts suppliers the plan is to
assemble equipment for manufacturing
auto parts and to build electrical boxes
the decision to build this second
Factory came after years of reflection
and analysis all Beck was surprised that
2017 started out so badly how make I
know things aren't buzzing here because
we don't have any orders at the moment
that's why the hall is empty the main
reason is the political changes in the
United States many international
companies have delayed investing here in
Mexico and it's affected us to three
contracts for orders that were about to
be signed were suddenly withdrawn
following Puebla is a commercial and
industrial center southeast of the
capital
since the 1960s Volkswagen has had a
plant here nearby the German company H
BPO produces front-end modules for VW
cars it recently invested millions in
new equipment
HBO has been in puebla for more than two
decades now decisions being made by US
president Donald Trump are already
impacting its business his statements
have generated a lot of noise they don't
let us work in peace
the tranquility we endured here for so
many years is gone now the statements
have generated a lot of instability HBO
locates its factories right beside the
carmaker's it supplies it delivers its
modules directly to the assembly line
car makers and their suppliers in Mexico
would be affected by any import taxes or
levies the u.s. might impose HBP Oh
would be hit but not critically wounded
we only export 16% of our goods to the
United States that's the extent to which
we would be affected 16% of course we
hope we wouldn't be had too hard HBO
sends parts over to VW several times a
day
the Mexican car industry had record
sales in 2016 and in February of this
year
Puebla is thriving but nobody knows for
how much longer
politicians in the city are concerned no
effect Oh given the changes that can be
expected with Donald Trump as US
president we're going to have to change
our priorities we're going to need to
bring forward plans for the mid term and
Accord them absolute priority the city
of Puebla is very dependent on the auto
industry but it is seeking to diversify
into other sectors the auto parts
suppliers want to become less dependent
on the United States as a market and
make more use of Mexico's free trade
agreements with other countries
Ullrich Tamaki voz is head of the
association of auto parts suppliers in
Puebla I've been promoting
diversification in the industry for a
long time we can't just look to America
we have to look to the entire world in
querétaro our back is also looking to
other branches we aren't feeling like
it's the end of the world we don't think
our markets are about to disappear or
that we won't have anything to do for
the next few years we do have a number
of orders in the pipeline but we're
certainly looking more actively for
other markets Sebastiaan a Lebec is
looking to move into green technology
and its global markets as a way to
protect his company from trumps America